foreign
let's have a little bit of fun yeah
apparently uh big gay lion was big gay
fired
this is real all right so it looks like
Brennan Schaub has fired his Handler if
you remember this guy Mark he actually
had his own podcast on the thick boy
YouTube channel better believe it haters
will say and now it looks like he's
turning into a hater because he's been
taking some shots at Brendan on
Instagram because he's obviously not too
happy about being fired and well this
man we should have seen this coming
because the first thing he did was take
him off a thick Boy network remember
where he made he made he made Mark make
his own channel Brendan hasn't even
acknowledged that he's left yet so
somebody asked him did they make an
announcement on the fighter and the kid
I missed it you have some great insights
reading an article
oh boy who's lined it well okay first
off who's this guy lying to Big Gay lion
and Brennan's former Handler responded
and said no I guess I'm not worse clip I
sent you is the closest I think that
Brendan has gotten to acknowledging it
okay I'll do that yeah yeah yeah
what happened to you on the fight in the
kid I was hoping you'd replace shab
whenever his liver inevitably failed and
then he laughed at that then also
somebody said seems like he got could do
she said some would say the good
douchiest so he's clearly hey Mark you
want to come on our show we'll let you
have a platform you want to talk about
it hey Mark come on and Dish Mark
open invite come on you want to talk
we'll have you on I'll be serious you
come on we will not good douche you we
won't learn gaduceu we promise
we will tell you that you're taking too
much because steroids not too happy with
Brendan I mean he's mocking him there
and he's laughing at the fact that
Brennan drinks a lot which is hilarious
because before this before he got fired
this guy would spend all day this is why
I like uh what was this guy too too lazy
to try this this is this is too lazy to
try I like too lazy to try more than
some of the other channels because they
a lot of them get very sensationalist
yeah but he gets he's just the fans that
aren't there and this guy's just kind of
like yeah and then like so then you said
this and here's a screenshot and then he
also said this which I have a screenshot
as opposed to like ooh this is like
there's some channels that really try to
stir [__] where he's like yeah so like
here's what happened in here in the
receipts
no and he is funny but I just mean he's
not here to be like whoa let's stir the
pie it's like that's our job can you
imagine being Let Go by Brendan Shaw
because you make him look stupid
that's a good point oh my God that's so
sad [__] wow dude when you're with that
is a good point when when you work for
Brendan Schaub and somehow you're a
liability like oh [__] look you just
bring the intelligence of the fighter
and the kids show down
what if what if Harley was the guy that
launched the Reddit investigation and
he's like look man you failed that
investigation yeah you really boned that
one to Media like he was always
responding they made him resign like
Comey he was even on Reddit a few times
responding to people I think I saw him
in my comment section A few times and
then also he had attacked kalila a lot
which was pretty funny and one time he
even attacked Theo I think Theo called
him protein Pony and then he like ran
today on Instagram bro that's a pretty
funny name a protein Pony so this guy
that one's one that's just a slow simmer
man the more I think about it Theo's
great man theobon's really funny come to
say that to me definitely had some good
moments but he was a bit of a loose
cannon I mean going after Theo while he
was still doing the king and the sting
that probably was oh wait can I see that
screenshot again go back because it said
something about him I'm not saying you
didn't say that [__] on my face or
whatever yeah like that that was
actually a spicy screen grab
uh no [__] dummy and there's a reason he
didn't say to my face isn't there it was
also immediately posted about it because
you're all upset oh yeah yeah but he was
a bit of a loose cannon I mean going
after yeah you know they bought Holly
he's a bit of a loose cannon he's still
doing you're going down for this club
you're going down for this big gay lion
I think that probably wasn't the best
move and then also during all the Bobby
Lee and koala drama you'd spend a lot of
time going after her which only made
things worse I think Brendan had to tell
him to stop after a while I'm starting
to see screenshots on Instagram of VMS
of um your cute little friend Mark
confirming that you wanted to expose me
kalila has just a destroyer of worlds
she's really a destroyer of worlds
the Red Rocket Queen the brother [__]
dude if she started like [__] Pepsi
I'd have to shoot pessie oh yeah just to
avoid this from coming we should shoot
just in case because the potential of it
happening I could I could you guys
actually think that I have potential to
[__] alive yes she [__] a dog at her
brother yeah yeah Betsy I think you got
a shot
thank you that's really that's the
nicest thing you've said to me in the
last two weeks it's because pessie's
penis looks like a dog's penis
is that correct but you've seen it I
didn't see it can you have it I can't
help it but nobody's talking about
[__] just walks around with it out
yeah rub my belly with him well no I
went to Mark and said dude you're making
things way worse from okay because he's
trying to defend me I went you're not
defending me you're making it worse
giving her Fuel and me and her are
talking you don't need to do this
Bobby Lee is there yeah oh my God he was
like three or four months ago he linked
some video to his Instagram like some
documentary exposing koyla and I'm sure
Brendan wasn't too happy about that
because
because at this point it seems like he
just wants nothing to do with her like
he does not want any drama involving her
again but now that Mark's not with
Brendan maybe he'll continue to go after
her because now nobody's holding him
back and maybe he'll go after Brendan
you know he could make a turnaround here
people might start liking him if that's
what he does and I also always thought
that this guy might have been part of
Brennan's team that found the production
and he hired him okay so
this is the closest and Virgie said this
is the closest spots it's gonna be the
best thing let's also look at our stress
levels oh that's number one number one I
have to fire some people number one
number one
yeah that's all it was just a little
Irish people
wow so wait is hater whoops sorry but
I'm a little bummed and I haven't
actually I love this the the [__] the
caption of this they call him protein
Pony gyno Gandalf DGL hello Mark Harley
what I'm saying about Mark Harley is
here is he still going to be doing a
show yes
or another episode out
I mean it's like
where is he doing it at because wasn't
he doing it at um no he has his own
channel now haters will say he'll be
doing it in a studio apartment oh his
Studio that he used was the same Studios
to fight her in the Kids Studio that
might explain why his short was just on
his phone yeah there hasn't been
anything in a month we're gonna see his
studio apartment you're right that's
what's coming next